après la vidéo d'il ya trois jours un
site internet proche d'al qaïda annonce
la prochaine diffusion d'un nouvel
enregistrement d'oussama ben laden
c'est un revers pour l'administration
bush six ans après l'ancien milliardaire
saoudien court toujours
il a échappé à l'une des plus grande
traque de l'histoire claude santerre
jamais dans l'histoire autant de moyens
civils et militaires
autant de bombardements d'opérations
terrestres et de technologie ont été
mises au service d'une simple chasse à
l'homme
la cible ben laden mise à prix cinq ans
millions de dollars depuis que le
congrès américain a doublé cet été la
récompense pour sa capture
comme on le disait au temps de la
conquête de l'ouest recherché mort ou
vif
en novembre 2001 débute premier épisode
le plus spectaculaire de la traque de
ben laden les américains pensent l'avoir
localisée dans les grottes de tora bora
à l'époque on imagine ben laden
retranché dans un abri ultra moderne
sous la montagne
après des bombardements très intensifs
les combattants anti taliban pénètre
dans les crottes de simples trous avec
parfois quelques munitions
les ben laden n'est pas là c'est la
première grande désillusion pendant des
mois des années les américains vont
intensifier leurs recherches en
afghanistan et fouillé les vallées
proche du pakistan
mais parfois on signale la trace de ben
laden à des milliers de kilomètres en
iran au yémen en somalie
personne ne sait où il se trouve et
certains annoncent même mort mais
régulièrement ben laden réapparaît à
travers des vidéos de propagande
après la capture de saddam hussein en
décembre 2003 le président bush
réaffirme sa détermination est en fuite
il ne fait certainement pas probablement
dans un trou quelque part pour échapper
à la justice
on l'aura quatre ans après ses
déclarations il y a quelques jours
nouvelle réapparition de ben laden dans
une vidéo
l'ennemi public numéro 1 toujours l'un
apparemment en pleine forme
invisible insaisissable ben laden six
ans après le 11-septembre réussit
toujours à échapper à ses poursuivants
bonsoir à l'achat